- [Mosher voiceover] Hey,
this is Moshe Kasher.
- [Natasha Voiceover]
And Natasha Leggero.
- [Mosher voiceover] We just
got married 6 months ago.
- [Natasha voiceover] Which
we think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love
advice to strangers.
- [Mosher voiceover]
So that's what we did.
We packed up the
car, hit the road,
and spread the love.
- [Mosher and Natasha voiceover]
This is The Honeymoon Tour.
(jazz music)
- Are you filming?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Before every show,
I liked these Scoops
- I had a joke about Scoops.
Probably couldn't
get away with it now,
'cause it's kinda a
little bit fat-shaming.
It was about a woman that
I once saw in an airport
and she had a king-sized
Snicker bar ice cream.
She was scooping
out the ice cream
with these Tostitos Scoops.
- Ew!
- Scooping out the ice cream
and eating it like,
all like--
- You can't do a joke like that
'cause it's fat-shaming?
- I mean I could do the joke,
but it might not work.
But isn't that funny?
- Yeah that is funny.
- Washing it down
with a king-sized
double-tall Red Bull.
- (Laughs)
- I was like, "You want to
be awake for this?" (laughs)
- Does anyone have
a real problem?
- A real question?
Want to come up?
- Something that
they would like--
- You can come up.
Not a joke one.
- Okay, hold on.
- Not a joke one.
- Wait, but hold one. Is he ...
Are you in a relationship?
- [Man] No.
- Oh you're not.
- Okay, we got a single.
All right, hold on.
What's your name?
- Zayer.
- Zayer?
- Very big fan of both of you.
- Thank you
- Thank you very much.
- My question is, "Why
do women love assholes?"
(laughter)
- [Moshe] You mean why
do women love jerks?
- Yeah. I don't know.
I try to be nice to them
but it's like every single time,
it just doesn't work out.
- [Amanda] Okay,
how old are you?
- Wait, say it again.
- I'm 19.
(audience boos)
- Woah. Way to be "boo".
Boo, "19". How developed
were you when you were 19?
(laughter)
Zayer's trying to understand.
You're basically saying, Zayer,
that you feel like the
women that you go after,
'cause you're a nice guy,
like mean people.
But maybe it's just that
you haven't found
the right person yet.
It's not about women,
it's just about the
people that you've met.
- So we can't make jokes
about fat, which I understand.
What else? Rape's
not funny anymore.
- I know, it sucks
that we live in a world
where rape's no
longer hilarious.
- Everyone used to
have a rape joke,
now you can't do 'em.
- I think you should
do rape jokes.
- They don't come to me anymore.
- 'Cause you're scared
of the backlash?
- Everyone's just become
more sensitive about it,
including me.
Well no, I'm just saying.
No, I'm just saying, sensitive
about joking about it.
- Right.
- Because comedy is, you know
you try to diffuse
terrible situations
by making jokes about it.
Absurd stuff. You know.
It's not like I think
rape is not horrible.
Of course it's horrible.
For eight years,
my strongest joke
was probably a rape joke.
Or five years.
- What is it?
- One time I knew this
girl, and she was like--
- This is a good
joke. I know this one.
- "You seriously never
been raped before?"
"No, why?"
"You never woke up at a party
and some guy was inside you?"
"I never woke up at a party."
- (Laughs) See?
- Also, I would like to add that
I kinda liked assholes
'til I was like 30,
so it's gonna take a little
bit of time to meet someone.
You might have to
grow up a little bit
and deal with some women.
What are you looking
for in a woman?
- I'm just looking to fuck 'em.
(audience laughs)
- Wait, wait, wait,
wait. Hold on.
Okay, he's like,
"I gotta question.
"Why are women, these
trifling ass women,
"all they want is
some man that'll
"use 'em, abuse 'em, and bounce.
"Me? I'm tryna'
fuck 'em and leave,
"but it's a different
kind of fucking."
- Okay, okay. Please
explain yourself.
- Okay so I just feel
like you shouldn't,
like for me, it's
cool if you wanna like
hook up with people and,
if you wanna have one-night
stands that's fine,
but for me I just
feel like you should
get to know someone first.
You know, see if they're cool.
See if you have
that relationship,
then you know that
could carry on to sex,
but it doesn't have to be like--
- I have the solution.
Hold on, Dan. I got, I know
what you need to do exactly.
Literally, you can't not do it.
You need to be 11 years
older than you are right now.
(audience cheers)